hey guys welcome to politics or welcome
back if you will I'm pretty sure that
most of you are already familiar with
this game if you're watching this video
but just as a very small introduction
pocket X is a theme-park simulator
developed by Texel Reptar and i think a
good way to describe it is basically how
Destructoid did which is it really has
that classic theme park vibe and I think
it's almost safe to say that it's roller
coaster tycoon but a modern take on it
really and it's actually funny because
it's also made by three people and
there's one designer guy and one
programmer guy and one music guy
basically so it's actually very similar
to roller coaster tycoon in that respect
but I also bring some new things to the
table obviously it has a completely
different art style it's very way too
acute and it has different things like a
more flexible coaster builder and MOT
supports but I'm advertising the game at
this point and I was not my point of
this whole talk about it basically the
game is going to be released on Steam
pretty soon and I actually got asked by
the developer or developers or one of
the developers if I could make a park to
help showcase the game in the trailer
and for screenshots for on the steam
page which was a really awesome question
to get so I was like well hell yeah I'm
gonna get started on that right away
and that's basically how things went but
that's quite a while ago right now a
couple of weeks ago and the trailer got
released one week ago it so I think at
this point I sort of just saved these
videos up until the trailer was all up
and viewed and now to get this series
going as a sort of more backstage video
of how the park that you can see in the
trailer of park sex was actually built
so yeah that's the entire idea behind
this when it comes to the park itself
it's very similar it's very simple
though I have to say I also couldn't use
any mods there are actually it's
remained this amount of mods for this
game at this point in time and many
different themes and also visual or
gameplay modes that you can mess around
with which are really good and easy to
use as well but
and the developers really wanted to keep
it vanilla for this video just to be
able to show off what the actual video
the game itself is like without having
well all of the input from mods which
can obviously transform a game and make
it look completely different than the
actual package that you get hence why
people go completely confused after
seeing moderate videos of rollercoaster
cone 3 which is a completely different
game nearly and another thing was sort
of a time constraints this was all done
over the course of a couple of days
before I went into the week of my exams
so I did have a bit of [ __ ] my exams
I'll just play parkzicht there but still
I didn't have too much time to work in
this park and it's also quite casual
it's nothing really supposed to be the
biggest park ever just sort of a park to
show off what you can actually do with
the game in the trailer and perhaps also
a bit in this video and it's also going
to not be a very bland Park or not at
all I say except for just a bit of you
know in mind planning sort of ideas that
you get I'm gonna do this certain thing
with an area but aside from that it's
really nothing special it's going to be
or at least the start is going to be
Alpine themed because I figured it's
quite feasible with the pieces that were
in the game the vanilla game which I had
at that point in time an important thing
to keep in mind also is that this we're
still a pre-alpha and still is a
pre-alpha so it's very early in
development and definitely don't have
all of the pieces and veil abilities of
the game yet and there's a lot more
still to come so it's very much like
planet coaster in that regard and yeah I
just wanted to see what you could really
do with the game at this point and just
try the Alpine theme first because I
it's something which I'm quite used to
at this point in time and feels really
safe but it's also something which the
limited building pieces in the game so
far are quite good for and you notice
that the building system is actually on
a grid but there is actually I think a
really interesting way in which the grid
works in this game for many pieces which
makes it much more versatile than you
would probably think when it's on a grid
though I can still definitely or at
least for me I feel like the grid is
still okay since the game isn't so
focused on making realistic parks but
really has more of that classic theme
parks in vibe and this is also why I
actually am against recording it in 3d
even though there are mole to be able to
actually open this game in 3d and I just
want to keep it in the vanilla isometric
mode which does more judge which does
more justice I should say to the way
that this game is really supposed to
beat really I feel at this very much in
books and spirit the older theme-park
games but in a newer way so I really
wanted to keep it isometric like that
but yeah the grid I think it's really
cool because there's a system with alt
and numbers like you can change the
placements of an object on the grid like
whether it's going to be on the lines or
in the middle of a grid tile and you can
also make the crea tiles smaller by
using out in combination with different
numbers which actually makes the grid
system much more versatile than I
initially expected and you're also able
to just place many different pieces for
which you can change the grid completely
free from the grid as well as you can
actually go quite off grid with certain
things as well so yeah it's really in
these things that I feel it still has
some of those qualities of the older
rollercoaster tycoon games but as much
as I've always felt like or as much as I
initially felt like it was a ripoff it
definitely moves forward in many
different things as well and it's much
easier to actually work with this game
to make some theme parks just for
aesthetic value then it probably was in
roller coaster tycoon 1 and 2 even
though there is still of course quite a
lack of content being so early in
development at the moment and there not
being that many mods yet so far also
something which I should probably say is
that I think the art style is definitely
something that just you have to be a fan
of or you really don't and it makes
quite a big impact I think on how much
you are going to like this game I don't
think I'll make any videos of
recommending games and sort of putting
them together and reviewing things I
think that's a job better left for other
people but I really feel like the
overall atmosphere
of this game is what really carries it
and that atmospheric goes through the
visuals the art style of the game but
also the little things like the way the
trees move when you place them and
really place things around them and
generally how the game feels in general
and I definitely know also some people
aren't really a big fan of this style
but I myself just kind of like it for
its cuteness I definitely would say it's
completely different from whatever would
really attract you to games like planet
coaster which I don't really make
comparisons to much so I definitely
won't talk about that any further but I
really feel like if you're more of an
old-school roller coaster tycoon one
person and then this probably fits you
more than if you were very much into the
moderate community of rollercoaster
tycoon 3 or perhaps even rollercoaster
tycoon 2 and it really depends on
whether you like the overall atmosphere
and look of this game anyway I just
wanted to make a small main street's
over here with some alpine buildings
which was also quite a nice way to also
see what we can really do with the
objects over here as usual what was
actually really cool was that I could
just message the developers on this
chord whenever I had an issue and was
lacking some stuff and just get some new
things that I was missing so I actually
see that through this series some new
update some new objects will actually
pop into the game and some new
functionalities will get in there and
make me replace certain parts of these
buildings at some point in the future
but aside from that this was just a
general try to make a very generic
Alpine ish main street's I'm not
entirely sure how I should narrow it
down and Alpine is a theme which is
really hard to categorize in any case
since there are so many different ways
of having the Alpine theme like whether
it's Switzerland or Austrian or northern
Italy actually makes a huge difference
and actually I feel like this might be a
bit more German than anything else when
it comes to the Alpine theme but it's
really what I felt was most feasible
with the pieces over here at this point
and also actually the best suited theme
to try different things
like you'll see I actually love using
chimneys to make pillows and actually a
great way to get some extra detail even
into footers sometimes and the same goes
for different pieces like you're able to
just use doorstep pieces or those side
door wall pieces to make cornerstone
into the buildings and things like that
which is quite interesting or being able
to place different wall types over each
other to make your own window shapes and
like over here is actually also
something which is not just a lot of fun
but I think also really great in the
sense that you're not so limited to what
you're given but you can really choose
and combine in certain pieces in this
game with being with things being so
much more off-grid than for instance in
a game like roller coaster tycoon to a
really big advantage in that as well of
course is the fact that you actually
don't have to worry about hit boxes and
you can just place things through each
other and since the textures in this
game are actually non-existence mostly
on especially the wall objects you don't
really have to worry about z-fighting
and can just get walls with the same
color over each other and have them
overlap which is quite useful as well as
well as the fact that the color picker
is well completely versatile of course
being a hex color picker I think that's
why they're called I'm pretty sure so
yeah that's pretty great as well I
should say though that I'm still of
course very much focused on building
things like usual on my videos but the
game is really also going to focus on
the gameplay aspect very much like the
original rollercoaster tycoon
which is something that still needs to
be fleshed out and which is very
work-in-progress at this point in the
pre-alpha so something to keep in mind
is that this maybe doesn't really
represent all of the angles from which
you can look at the game but this really
goes from this really goes for all of my
videos in general
but yeah it's mostly an exploration of
what you can do with the scenery in the
game which is still quite a lot of fun
though it's really down to the way how
much I like the graphics and how cute
they are so I don't know usually I've
heard people say if you're into the
older rollercoaster tycoons or into very
cutesy games I think this is actually a
really cool game to try but I should
actually probably say that the best way
to check out whether you should get this
game or any other coaster game is just
to check out videos I think actually
nerd cube has a really good video
comparing Park sites to roller coaster
tycoon world and planet coaster that's
hopefully off topic though I just feel
that even though this game borrows a lot
from the older rollercoaster tycoon
games and definitely wouldn't be there
if they wouldn't exist it really has its
own little style and some of the things
which I love which I can't really
advertise for but some some of the more
personal things are really how cute the
sound design and how good the signers
are sound design in general really is
and the fact that you have different
sounds for objects that you place onto
the ground and that things move a little
bit when you place them and you get this
little gust of wind around the object
that you place and just the overall
feeling of the game with all the little
effort that all the effort that goes
into the little details it's what is
worth it for me in the end but that's
really not what this series is focused
on also I should definitely say I'm not
affiliated with the developers and I
didn't get the I didn't get any money or
the games but it's just a game which I
really like playing so there you go
that's about that though in the
in-between this and all the other games
that I'm playing and school I don't
really have too much time for it but
yeah that's basically the entire story
around it I should also say I am
actually a really big fan of the
gameplay aspect as well so while I
probably won't focus on that in any
videos anytime soon and it still needs
to be fleshed out in the game definitely
it's something which I do enjoy a lot
and roller coaster tycoon the originals
probably my favorite game of all time
and probably also the one that I've
played most of all games ever
so it's something which I am thinking
about just something which I'm not
really doing at this point in time I
also may actually get into a moderate
series of this game if I find some time
in the future and practice a little bit
more with it and by the time some more
mods and updates will also come out then
definitely it's something which I'll
pick up in the future but right now the
only thing to really look forward to is
this game's eventual steam release which
is going to have a pretty soon and I'm
actually gonna link it in the
description of this video just in case
and that is if I don't forget it which
I'll probably do but yeah that's
something where you can check it out at
least
now this last building was just a bit of
a the thing where I actually wanted to
try different colors you don't see too
many red planks on Alpine buildings
definitely a more Japanese thing but
it's something which I just wanted to
try just to get different colors in here
one of the things which I do like is
even though the visuals are very simple
and this goes for the models and
textures by having that very versatile
color picker you can get the very minor
differences in colors between buildings
which well it doesn't seem like it would
affect the overall look of Main Street
too much it actually makes a really big
difference if you just have those very
minor differences in colors between
buildings to make it seem a little bit
more realistic and differentiate them a
little bit from each other and this
definitely goes for all of the details
but especially in the case of a Alpine
main streets where you have to work with
a lot of wooden planks I think it's best
to just get some very or at some
slightly different shades of brown or
even related colors and add them to the
buildings also something to not be
afraid of I think is to go with some
less Orthodox colors for the planks like
really green doesn't even look too bad
for planks either and red can always be
a pretty good choice as well how uneven
an orange-ish shade would actually be
pretty good in some cases and also
something to keep in mind when you're
playing pocket X is that pillars I mean
chimneys are absolutely everything
though mostly pillars you can actually
use them for quite a lot more than just
being chimneys and I also have to say
that it was actually this game the
sparked my love for chimneys has
different objects definitely anyway
that's a we're talking to and this video
on but this is all I have for today
so thank you guys for watching and I'll
see you guys in the next episode in
which I'll finish the main streets it'll
be quite a short episode and same goes
for the rest of the episodes of the
series probably but I'll just take all
points of the park in bite-sized videos
anyway see you guys later